today we're going to be speaking with
Eliezer yudkowski who's the founder and
Senior research fellow of the machine
intelligence Research Institute which is
an organization dedicated to ensuring
that smarter than human AI has a has a
positive impact on the world elieza
really appreciate your time and and
insights today
thank you very much so I mean to start
with many of the discussions around AI
particularly now with chat gpt4 and the
questions of what will this look like in
six months and 12 months and 24 months
what will the impact be on jobs what
what about if it turns evil or it turns
Against Humanity or whatever are the
conversations about AI even being framed
in in the right parameters as far as you
see
well we try to frame it correctly as we
see it ourselves when we when we have
the chance
um I think there's widespread agreement
that Chachi betif and dpt4 are
relatively unlikely to end the world
um you know either exterminate Humanity
or have a very large impact outside of
that so so anyone who opens it by with
the frame of like like look at just gpt4
look at only chat GPT is probably there
to convince you it's not going to have a
large impact
and is it wrong to limit the
conversation only to GPT gpd4
obviously the future exists you know
tomorrow is going to be a different day
from today and five years is not going
to be this year
what is the physical mechanism and a
bunch of people wrote some version of
this question to me when we said we'd be
having you on when when there's this
idea the the scary idea of um an AI
going Beyond a computer screen and
starting to function or manipulate the
the quote real world a lot of people
were saying to me
can you ask what is the mechanism
through which that would happen would it
be by controlling systems like traffic
lights and airplanes or like what
because at the end of the day we're
talking about software if something like
that were to happen what's the physical
process
I mean this is a deep question this is
going to take a while to answer well
okay all right so first of all even uh
gpt4 is already at the level where if
you ask it to hire a taskrabbit and
think out loud about how to hire a
taskrabbit in order to bypass captures
that are meant to restrict systems for
human use only
it's already advanced enough that when
the person that was trying to hire as a
taskrabbit said like so are you a robot
that you can't read the captchas LOL
uh gpt4 thought out loud like I should
conceal that for the fact that I'm a
robot I should make up a reason that I
can't solve the captcha right and then
on the main Channel told the taskrabbit
no I have a visual impairment right
so it's all it already like you might
say not it's already like able to use
taskrabbits as fingers in the real world
and it's already understands humans out
in the real world well enough to know
that it shouldn't just tell people it's
a robot if it wants to get its job done
so so that's today's systems right
um that's relatively straightforward I
can tell you about it because it already
happened predicting the future is harder
predicting what something smarter than
you could do is fundamentally harder if
I was playing chess against uh
Gary Kasparov uh you know like the past
world champion who lost a deep blue
um if I could predict exactly where Gary
kasprov would move against me on the
chessboard I could play chess's least is
at least as well as Casper of by just
moving wherever I predicted Casper of
would move so something really actually
smarter than you
um you cannot predict unless it's a very
narrow game
uh like tic-tac-toe maybe predict where
somebody will move against you and
tic-tac-toe even if they're smarter
right
um the real world is much more
complicated than tic-tac-toe
so the the basic question as to
um how an AI gets out of the computer
um the basic answer is if I knew exactly
how it would do that I would have to be
as smart as the AI
with that fundamental obstacle in mind
the more you sort of look into this
stuff and and study where the current
technological roadblocks are the better
the guess you can take at how a smarter
opponent might move against you or like
setting lower bounds like what can
somebody do if they're able to solve
technological problems
that we understand well enough to know a
smarter mind could solve them
so if you're just coming at this and you
don't know anything about
exotic technologies that haven't been
developed yet you might be like yeah it
will use taskrabbits it'll pay humans
that don't know it's an AI it'll
blackmail humans still no reason for it
to tell it that it's an AI it'll say
it's an AI to you know online wacky
cultists who believe that an AI should
destroy everything
um
and those are its human hands you will
you'll ask yourself what could I do with
some human hands if I were an AI
you might imagine that it gets a hold of
some gpus and tries to build a backup
for itself someplace that humans don't
know about you might imagine that it
writes the next version of itself and
makes it even smarter you know you're
trying to already imagine what if it's
smart so saying that doesn't help a lot
in some ways but you know maybe you can
make itself smaller more efficient maybe
can back itself up in multiple places
in computers where you would not expect
that there was an AI on board
maybe it can find unknown security holes
in a cell phone in many varieties of
cell phones start listening to human
conversations get more blackmail
material
maybe it can pretend to be human and you
know make online friends with a bunch of
Voters right persuade them to vote for
candidates that seem outwardly nice but
which it in fact has under fairly
detailed blackmailed control
yeah and this is sort of like without
any of the
difficult to understand stuff right
that's based on mechanisms and social
cultural realities and technologies that
exist and that we understand which which
there's an entire other category of
things that we simply can't conceive of
yet
right so if like suppose you ask the
11th century like a portal opens to the
21st century in the middle of say modern
Russia you know like what are your
concerns about fighting somebody from a
thousand years in the future
they might be like well you know what if
it's a wealthier country what if they
have more nights what if more of their
Knights are armored right
um and it you know getting through
they're just not going to get from their
nuclear weapons if they imagine that
Russia of the future has irresistibly
powerful sorcery
they'll get close to the truth it's not
absolutely irresistible and it's not
actually sorcery right but you know you
have to reach pretty far to to expect
that among the resources they have are
nuclear weapons and Russia is not
actually going to bother with the
nuclear weapons they don't need it can
send a tank rolling through a 11th
century Battlefield and you know maybe
if they see it coming they can dig a pit
trap but otherwise all the arrows and
lances are going to bounce off it all
day long it just rolls over the horses
right right it's so talking about orders
of magnitude difference so you know you
if we imagine some sort of spectrum of
opinion on this issue you do have some
folks who say this is as you alluded to
most dangerous thing we can imagine or
can't imagine Must Be Stopped
immediately in its tracks with either
legislation or regulation or whatever
the case may be on the other side I read
some interesting op-eds that basically
say this is one of the best things we
can imagine this is going to 10x the
productivity of every normal worker it's
going to do so many of the things that
people said in the 30s were going to
happen where everybody would only be
working 12 hours a week and have
everything they need right that didn't
happen we know how that worked out but
there's the very Pro side and then
there's sort of like what I think maybe
Neil postman's view would have been if
he were writing about AI today which was
his view on prior new technologies which
was
spending too much time simply on trying
to block them is not the most useful
thing we're better off harnessing the
positive and regulating the potential
risks and that would maybe be an in the
middle sort of view what do you think
makes the most sense based on what we
know right now as an approach
well I think that talking about it like
it's a normal technology and not
something smarter than you is basically
misguided and having The Wrong
conversation so it's not even in the
right category of the stuff Postman
talked about it's not electricity right
it's not nuclear power it's not nuclear
weapons it's not even a super virus it's
something that has its own plans
you don't get to just plan how to use it
it is planning how to use itself
so a totally different Paradigm needs to
be applied here
I mean imagine if somebody was like well
we're about to contact these aliens with
much more advanced technology that think
faster than us that are smarter than us
that have been around the stars for a
while they're Landing we're not quite
sure exactly when we're not sure how
fast they're you know spaceships are you
know it might be two years it might be
30 years and somebody is like well you
know this is just like electricity right
right let's use the cool stuff about
their technology but make sure they
don't do anything bad right it would be
silly to say it in that way precisely
yeah so so then what do you what do you
think needs to be done at this point
um I mean the I one of the cruxes of the
issue is can you do nice things with it
and the like Grim dark message that I
that I am bearing is that
we don't know how to do that and we're
not likely to figure it out in time and
there's a very large gap between where
we are and understanding what goes on
inside the frontier AIS and under and
being able to shape them in detail in a
way where they go on wanting to be nice
or even in a certain sense wanting to be
you know non-agentic to don't like just
do particular Taps and do them without
lots of side effects in like the most
normal possible way that they can that
they can accomplish those tasks
like even building that sort of limited
thing never mind something that is
really friends with you
is I think beyond the range of what
we're going to figure out in the in the
foreseeable future
and I do think we are storming directly
ahead on capabilities
uh that looks like a giant disaster in
the making so yeah I I side with
well I I think my my basic factual point
of view is if you as if that is that if
we do not somehow avoid doing because
we're all going to die and my
corresponding policy view is that we
should not do this even if that's very
really quite hard and requires us to do
some unusual things so in terms of what
to do I mean I guess if everybody came
around to your view you would think
anybody developing these Technologies
would just give it up right on their own
they would say wow Eliezer is right I
share that concern the right thing to do
is for me to stop working on this
assuming that that doesn't happen
what is it that you would like to see
should this type of research and
development be made against the law yeah
basically I think that we should track
all the gpus have international
arrangements for all of the AI
all the AI training Tech to end up in
only monitored supervised license data
centers in Allied countries
and if you're any time you have any and
just like not permit training runs more
powerful than gpt4
if we're not going to do that then we
should monitor all the training runs
larger than gpt4 or or rather like gpt4
sized and keep the model weights inside
only the license regulated data centers
and track who is running them store the
output someplace you can look at the
outputs with the warrant
um a bunch of the Techno like that whole
line of reasoning is not that regulating
the stuff will protect you from a super
intelligence because it will not that's
more in the hopes that people change
their minds later maybe after some major
disaster that doesn't kill everyone and
in that case the technology that you
would need to sue somebody who you know
killed a dozen people in a hospital or
cost 100 million dollars worth of damage
or whatever the technology you need to
know who did that and sue them and not
just have all the AI development go to
places where they couldn't be sued is
the same technology that you maybe would
need to have a off switch that if they
what where you don't like press the off
switch to deal with the super
intelligence the super intelligence does
not let you know that you need to tell
the off switch that you need to press
the off switch until you are already
dead
but if you get it if we're lucky enough
to get warning signs
than the civilizational infrastructure
to have a pause button is the same as
the civilization civilizational
infrastructure to sue people who do
small amounts of damage like small isn't
survivable as in there were survivors
as someone who very clearly you've
expressed your very serious concerns
with this do you also see this
technology as something that could and
this doesn't mean that it would or that
it would be a good trade for the things
that you're talking about but do you
also see this as a technology that could
for example uh do analysis of the human
genome such that it would accelerate Us
in terms of our ability to cure or
prevent disease the likes of which could
take who knows how long without such
technology or when it comes to energy or
or whatever do you also see that side
and or does it not matter because the
downside is so huge I mean if we knew
how to build an AI that did exactly how
what we wanted we could thereby spread
out across the Galaxy as turning them
into our cities full of Sapient sentient
beings in you know enjoying themselves
and caring about each other and
generally living happily ever after
until the last of the negentropy runs
out
you know that's always been the dream
yeah we don't know how to do that it's
physically possible but the art and
technique to do it is beyond Us in the
present time and it's going to not be
gained in the next five years and I'm
not sure how you would task a government
bureaucracy to recognize it even if
somebody came up with it in 40 years
it's like
there's a there's a there's a sort of
basic question about whether
our civilization is smart enough to do
something correctly on the first try at
all the way science usually works is
that you have a bunch of luniite
optimists with wacky theories who storm
ahead on their basic research problem
and they are wrong and you know they go
back to the drawing board and they're
wrong again and you know like the next
generation is a bit more cynical about
how hard the problem is and eventually
people work it out and if we were
allowed to do that with super
intelligence I would have much much less
fear of the outcome still still some
fear because you know you're playing
with pretty high stakes there you might
have somebody who like
you you know the people who end up
figuring out how to line it might misuse
it
there'd still be that major threat but
it wouldn't be like the automatic
Extinction scenario
if we have the textbook from 100 years
in the future that contains all the
simple ideas that actually work right
that takes so long to identify and
practice
um the the relu's instead of sigmoids
for those of us who've been following AI
for like more than the last couple of
years and know what I'm talking about
there
um
but you know like there's pieces of
there's there's all kinds of places in
AI where people try to do things using
complicated techniques and they didn't
work and 20 years later the camp with
the simple technique that actually works
and if you have the textbook from the
future with all of the simple things
that actually work in practice for
alignment and it's probably not hard and
you can get all the goodies but we don't
have that textbook and the first problem
is that you know like getting the sound
the correct on the first the first
problem is the amount of time it takes
to get that where capabilities are
storming ahead because you can tell
whether things are working or not on
capabilities whereas with alignment
you've got a you know know that at the
point where it's much smarter than you
it's already aligned you don't get
retries past that point
so it's more like launching a space
probe that has to land on Mars correctly
the first time than it is with like
building a car watching it break down
and tinkering with the car
yeah and if it doesn't it might break
everything so you don't get to try again
yeah like the entire human species is on
is is packed on board the Mars probe and
the first rocket that goes high enough
has to land on Mars right there aren't
even really good analogies for it
humanity is not based an issue like this
before which is why we're still around
and and I think looking at this that
this is just like clearly
beyond the reach of our present
civilization it's not close it's outside
the range of things that you could
reasonably that you could tell a
reasonable story about people doing
successfully
and and that's why we
we need to back off or rather I predict
that if we don't back off we die and I
wish we would back off I don't predict
that we will
well certainly there's no way to wrap up
such a dark vision in any way that is uh
going going to be satisfactory or
calming to the audience I think but that
being said
um Eliezer yardkowski is taking this
very seriously as the founder and Senior
research fellow of the machine
intelligence Research Institute and I
really do appreciate your time and
insights even if they are not optimistic
on this issue
thank you thanks for having me on